- [Koang] We want Nebraska
to be recognized as
a basketball state.
Within the next few years,
South Sudanese players are
gonna infiltrate the game massively,
and I want Omaha to be the center of that
because this is where the community is.
My name is Koang Doluony,
I am the founder and
executive director of
the Omaha Talons Academy.
We are a basketball program
dedicated towards serving
the South Sudanese population.
Omaha is the largest
population of South Sudanese
outside of Africa.
From the moment that I picked up a ball,
it was something that
I knew I wanted to do
and I wanted to get better at.
When I got the chance to
become the player that I was
and ending up in a division
one school and realizing,
hey, I know guys that are
just as good, that are
just as capable, who are
built to play this game.
You know, the only thing that's really
missing is, it’s the training.
This is where it all started,
a few kids wanted to get
some basketball lessons, right here.
You know, right here on
this concrete is where
we would work on our stuff.
We started this program
in 2012, four years later
these guys are incredible players.
I'm probably spending
more time on the phone
with high level division
one coaches than I ever
had at any point in my life.
Aguek has been probably one of
the best players in the state
since seventh grade, the
community has wrapped its arms
around him and we want
to see Aguek do well.
- I started with the Omaha Talons
when I was in middle school.
I was Gatorade Player of the Year
for the state of Nebraska in 2016.
I just think a lot about basketball and of
all the fortune I've had with it.
I was born in South Sudan,
and I came over to the
United States when I was four.
- We come from a journey that's really,
really, really painful.
A lot of us were born in refugee camps.
It almost felt like the
world is not designed for us.
We've been on the run for
as long as I can remember,
trying to find a home one
country after another.
I grew up in the south Omaha projects.
I came here at nine years old.
It made us men, it gave us
enough challenges by the time
that we're 18, 20 years old we're ready
to take on the world.
Most people look at this
thing here, you know, and they see
a clothes hanger; this was
actually our first basket.
I remember being yea-high
and grabbing a ball
and trying to dunk on each other.
Basketball has created a really, really,
really special brotherhood.
- It brings a lot of joy to my
heart to see all these other
Sudanese kids just really making
something out of nothing,
'cause when we first came here, we really
didn't have anything.
- I'm really excited, I think
Omaha should be excited,
and I think the basketball
world should be really,
really excited about
what's gonna' be comin'.
We can see it very clearly,
you know, it's just a matter of
time and working.
(bell reverberating)